thank you
can you see that
sunrise
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
ly powerful memory
vivid memory
memory
of the most beautiful and healthy
pristine coral reef
foreign
that you know it took a year to prepare
for this Expedition but actually
it's taking us 12 years to be to be 12
years
it's like a family reunion and you know
being back with my friends in the same
place is
very special
great help
to me there was a before and after 2008.
in 2008 I went to National Geographic
and proposed this idea let's go to the
wildest place in the ocean and help to
protect them before it's too late and
that's how pristencies was born
the first explanation we did was the
Southern Line Islands in 2009 12 years
ago
so all of a sudden you are offered an
incredible opportunity to visit probably
one of the most pristine places left on
the planet
what's not to like
and the first dive we found this
incredible Coral Reef
in some places 90 percent of the bottom
was covered by lifecore
[Music]
not only the coral was spectacular but
so many more fish
including quite a bit of sharks
this place is so beautiful I remember
coming out of the first dive and saying
this is the best knife I've done in my
life
so for us it was like
we got in a time machine and went back
500 years
and found a world that nobody had seen
before
[Music]
we found a world so pristine that it
completely shifted our understanding of
what coral reefs look like
[Music]
I immediately thought wow how many
places are left like this this is rare
this is unique we need to make sure that
these places are protected forever
we work with the government of kiribas
to ensure that 12 miles around the
islands would be close to fishing
forever
but every number of years
the Pacific Ocean gets warmer than usual
for a few weeks that's what's called El
Nino events
in 2015 and 16
there was a warming event that took the
number of weeks above the threshold not
four or five but to 16.
it was the most massive warming event
that we have ever recorded
corals are very delicate animals
if they go above a certain temperature
they die
or friends from Scripps returned in 2017
to the Sutherland Islands
and what they found was really
heartbreaking
those Rifts had lost a half of the
corals
even the most pristine coral reefs in
the world with that huge abundance of
fish we're not able to cope with 16
weeks of temperatures far above average
[Music]
now we're coming five years later
see if the reef that pristine most
pristine Reef in the world
has been able to bounce back
so it was really important when we came
back to see if that loss
was something I was gonna have to mourn
for the rest of my life
or to see if this location could rebuild
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
from the surface to as far as I could
see
[Music]
layers and layers of Coral Place intact
[Music]
and my first thought was
yes
reef is resilient this street has come
back
[Music]
I felt the same thing as when I first
Jam here in this clear water
like
revisiting all memories
[Music]
what a life
the most amazing Reef I have seen
[Music]
actually it's better than I remembered
this is one of the most beautiful places
on the entire planet
[Music]
I talk to my friends that work on choral
recruitment they said okay well maybe in
20 years you'll have a reef back
yeah this is four years no I I
completely agree it's it's amazing
getting imagery that we saw in 2013 2017
2021 uh if we can't make a case that
Islands won't grow back fast from those
data
we need to turn in our degrees Yeah
we had a good opportunity to show some
of the data from the Southern Line
Islands at an international meeting of
coral reef scientists when I showed the
final imagery of what we saw in 2021 I
saw people's jaws drop
had we seen some initial Coral growth I
think we would have been happy
[Music]
see that our expectations
there are as many corals now as there
were before the warming event and at
Flint actually more of the bottom is
covered by Coral than when we first came
here in 2009
foreign
based on all the data we have I think we
have a pretty good answer why the Corals
in the Line Islands are so resilient
it is because of the protection
the fact that there is no fishing there
has allowed the fish to reach abundances
that are of the charts and all these
fish are gracing grace and grace and
grazing all day long everywhere
they prevent the algae the seaweed from
overgrowing the dead corals so they keep
the reef clean
allowing the corals to come back we
[Music]
all felt such relief
working with our partners and local
communities pristine sis is helping to
turn the tide for ocean protection
but our work is not done yet the
[Music]
urgency
to protect coral reefs around the world
is greater than ever
and what these riffs are telling us loud
and clear is that we need to preserve
the pristine reefs that are left and we
need to protect many of the reefs so
they can come back like we have seen
here in the Sutherland Islands
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]